Today, we start the Odyssey.
And the Odyssey is a sequel to the
Iliad,
and it's a family story. It's a story
about a homecoming. There are three main
characters, right? There's uh Odysseus.
Sorry.
Odysseus,
who is the main character, and that's
why it's it's called the Odyssey.
Um then there is
Penelope,
who is
his wife, and there's Telemachus,
who
is
their
son.
>> [snorts]
>> And as we discussed when we um
read the Iliad, Homer is first and
foremost
concerned about the human condition.
What does it mean to be human?
What does it mean to live in a world of
war, of trauma, of tragedy? And how can
we
overcome uh this adversity?
So, um
the Odyssey is about three individuals
and a family, and they're all
traumatized. They're all heartbroken.
Okay? So, Odysseus
is we trying to return home from the
war.
And his problem is that he has PTSD,
which is post-traumatic stress disorder.
And this is very common for soldiers who
return from war. They've seen so much
violence, they've seen so much tragedy,
they've seen so much senseless death,
that their souls are shattered. And that
is Odysseus' problem.
Then you have Penelope, who's suffering
from depression.
And why is she depressed?
Because her husband has been away for 20
years.
And she doesn't know if
he's alive
or he's dead.
He's probably dead, right? It's been 20
years. There's been no sign of him for
the past 20 years, but she cannot bring
herself to admitting that
um he's dead. So, she's put herself in a
very
precarious situation. There's dozens of
suitors who want her hand in marriage.
And she she wants to say no,
but she's afraid that if she does that,
then uh she'll be alone for the rest of
her life. But, she doesn't want to say
yes because she refuses to
admit
that her husband, the love of her life,
Odysseus is dead. In her heart, she
feels that he's still alive, but in her
head, she cannot justify it. She cannot
explain it. It's just a feeling in her.
Okay? And so, her response, and this is
what we call cognitive dissonance.
Her response is just to shut down.
Okay? She just spends all her time alone
in her room.
At first, she's weaving stuff, but then
she just sits in her room.
All right?
And then there's Telemachus.
Telemachus, his problem is that
his he doesn't know if his father is
dead or alive.
But, the man is a legend. This is a man
who won the Trojan War by coming up with
a stratagem with the Trojan Horse.
Okay? So, he is a legend in this world,
and everyone sings his praises.
And he's his son, so he's living in his
shadow, okay?
And he wants to prove he's better than
his father.
He wants to become a hero himself, but
he's being
burdened by the legacy of his father.
The other issue is that unless his
father is dead, he cannot inherit his
father's legacy, right? His prop- the
property,
uh the reputation cannot be transferred
to him. Then there's his mother, who is
just sitting around the house every
single day.
If she were to get married, she would
leave, and then he could be master of
his own house, right?
But she's still around, so he's kind of
stuck. At the same time, the suitors are
waiting for Penelope's answer, which is
never going to come. So, they're just in
the house, and they're eating up all
um his wealth.
So, he is just seeing his life wither
away, and there's nothing he can do
about it.
All right? So,
um he is just depressed as well, and
he's angry.
But, you know, all these things are the
same thing. It's really one of cognitive
dissonance. It's really one of
depression. It's really one of trauma.
All right? So,
there's another way we can analyze
what's going on, and to think about the
soul.
And the soul is something that the
ancients
were really concerned about, because it
was really the most fundamental issue of
what it means to be a human being. It's
something that we don't talk about
today. Something that we don't think
about today, because we live in a world
of material science. If you can't see
it, it doesn't exist.
But, uh for most of humanity, uh for
sorry, for most of human history,
humanity has understood the soul as very
present, and as very real, and the most
significant thing in our lives, okay?
So, the soul that they understood,
um let let's talk about their
understanding of the soul. And this is
true for a lot actually a lot of
cultures.
First of the soul
is a very complex thing, okay?
[clears throat] It has almost infinite
dimensions.
The different layers
to the soul. And this really a part of
the soul
that is you, okay?
That is you, the person.
But who you are as a person is
ultimately influenced by other
influences as well, by other factors as
well, okay? So,
these influences include your family,
okay? Your culture,
the history,
um, and maybe the gods, okay? So,
again, there are infinite dimensions and
these dimensions have an impact on you.
And maybe when you die, maybe there's a
part of you that lives on, okay? But
there's also parts of you that flows
back into these different streams
of the universe.
Okay, so it's a very complex thing.
Now, the soul,
another name for the soul that we use
today,
uh, if you go to psychology class, their
name for the soul is the worldview.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay? So, we have a much more simplistic
understanding
of our psychology than the ancients.
They didn't know the worldview is just
our understanding of who we are,
>> [snorts]
>> where we came from, and our place in the
universe.
Okay? It comes and we believe it comes
from our memories
and our experiences.
Okay?
And [snorts]
the worldview is important
because it allows us to understand us
and ourselves. This is important for
things such as planning.
Right? Only if you know who you are, can
you actually plan ahead?
Because then you know what you want to
do, what you want to accomplish, okay?
It allows for
empathy,
building relationships with others,
okay? It allows for judgment.
Basically,
>> [snorts]
>> what's good, what's bad. What do you
like? What don't you like, okay?
So, the worldview and the soul are
fundamental to who we are.
Now,
in psychology, what they will teach you
is that trauma
splinters the worldview,
okay? There's something about your
experience
that is fundamental to your identity,
>> [snorts]
>> but
um because it is so painful, you forget
about it. Or you refuse to see it. And
this causes a rupture
in your identity, in your coherent sense
of the world, which destroys your
worldview, okay? And this leads to
depression. What is depression?
Depression is the inability
to act and to think, okay?
You don't know what you want to
accomplish.
You don't trust yourself. You don't know
what you like. And so what what's what's
of depression? You sleep a lot.
You find no pleasure in anything.
You
feel no emotion. You feel sort of
numbness, okay? And that's why people
they tend to take drugs, or they just
sleep all the time, or whatever, okay?
All right? Because you're unable to act.
And that's exactly what's happening
to Odysseus, Penelope, and Telemachus.
All right? There's a trauma in their
lives, okay? And they just believe this
as well. Okay? There could be a trauma
that splits the soul.
Okay? And it could be a demon. It could
be um
a really painful incident. It could be
anything. Okay? But it splits your soul.
And if you are to recover, then you have
to repair your soul. And that's a
fundamental conflict and the dilemma
within the Odyssey. You have three
individuals
Odysseus, Penelope, Telemachus. Their
soul has been splintered. And so when
they're on a journey,
their own Odyssey
to repair their soul.
>> [snorts]
>> And the answer, of course, is each
other. Okay? Their love for each other.
That's what's what That's what's going
to save the world. Okay? The love of
family.
And that is the fundamental message
of
the Odyssey.
All right? And that's why it's such a
powerful read.
Okay. So, let me give you some
background as to the plot.
So,
um as you know, the Odyssey begins in in
media in median res. Okay? In the middle
of things. Which is to say that a lot of
things have already taken place and it
happens just in the middle of the plot.
Okay? In the In the In the In the
beginning, Odysseus has been away for 20
years.
And he's stuck on an island with
Calypso. All right? Penelope is
depressed and sitting by herself in the
room. Telemachus is angry. Okay? Athena
comes and tells Telemachus, "Come with
me. I will help you find your father."
Okay?
>> [snorts]
>> Um
so
uh
>> [sighs]
>> The story starts with the Trojan War, of
course. Okay? So, remember the Tro-
There's the Helen has been taken to
Troy. She falls in love with Paris
because that's what Aphrodite promised
Paris as a prize.
Um and now her husband, the king of
Sparta, Menelaus, and uh
um
and his brother, Agamemnon, the king of
kings, are like, "We're going to raise
an army and we're going to get back
Helen, okay?" And this is
prophesized. This is This is to be the
greatest war in human history. It will
make It will make mortals into gods,
right? That's why Achilles enters this
war. Because this is the opportunity for
him to prove that he is the greatest
warrior of all in all of human history.
And that's why he goes to Troy.
Odysseus
is also
supposed to go to this war. But
Odysseus, he's different from Achilles.
Because Odysseus loves his wife,
Penelope.
And he has a new son, 6 months 6 months
old, Telemachus. So he's conflicted. And
he really doesn't want to go to war. But
the Greeks need him because the gods
have told the Greeks that it is really
Odysseus who will win the war. He is the
one who will come up with the Trojan
horse, the stratagem that will win this
war. So you need this guy. Okay? So
Odysseus doesn't want to go, but the
Greeks insist. So the Greeks send two
messengers to uh Ithaca,
um where Odysseus lives. Now Odysseus,
what he does is
he pretends to be mad. So he dresses up
like a beggar, okay? He's a king, but he
dresses up really badly. He's going
around the farmland and throwing salt
everywhere he goes. He looks crazy,
okay? And you throw salt in the land to
kill crops. So he looks kind of crazy.
But the But the Greeks understand that
this is a man of disguises. He's a man
of stratagems. He's very clever. So it's
probably a trick. So what they do is
they take his 6-month-old son,
Telemachus, okay, and put him in front
of Odysseus. Now, Odysseus is plowing
the field and salting the fields, okay?
And basically the task is this, if
you're really mad, you're going to run
over your son, Telemachus, and kill him.
If you're not mad, if you're not really
crazy, then you're going to stop and go
somewhere else and save your son. So, so
let's see if you're really crazy.
>> [snorts]
>> And so, Odysseus, of course,
uh turns away and saves his son. And the
Greeks are like, "Ha, you see? You're
tricking us all along. Come with us to
uh Troy." And so, Odysseus has no choice
but to go.
Okay?
So,
this is why Odysseus goes. He's forced
to go. But you think about it, this
story doesn't really make any sense,
right? And that's the
um greatness of Homer because he's
telling us the complexity of human
psychology.
Odysseus is really, really smart. He
thinks ahead, right?
He should know that if he were to have
this stratagem, the Greeks would see it
see through it really quickly, right?
So, what he should be doing is hiding
from the Greeks, right?
Or maybe um just moving away. If you
really, really don't want to go to this
war, you just run away and take your
family with you. Okay? Or, you know
what? Just kill these guys because
you're crazy, right?
All right, so
um what this tells us is that yes,
um Odysseus really loves his family and
he wants to be with his family because
he knows that if he goes to Troy, he'll
be gone for 20 years.
That's 20 years
um that that he won't be able to see his
son, Telemachus, grow up, okay?
But at the same time, this is the
greatest war in human history. Achilles
is going, Agamemnon is going. Does
Odysseus want to be really want to be
left out?
Does he really want to be the one guy uh
who's like a coward? Who's like, "You
know what? I'm just going to stay home."
Right? The Greeks will just laugh at him
for the rest of his life saying, "You're
just a pussy."
Right? You've been whipped by your
wife. He doesn't want to do that. So,
it's a conflict. Right? So, what he does
is he comes up with a stratagem that
allows the Greeks to see through it
really quickly and force him to go so he
doesn't have to be any responsibility
for what he does.
All right? And that is the complexity of
the human soul. That is the complexity
of our worldview.
All right?
So, he goes to Troy
and
he has to explain himself why he's
there. And he he knows he's going to be
away from home for 20 years, 10 years in
Troy, 10 years being lost at sea. All
right? So, his worldview is this.
Why am I here in Troy? Well, the first
reason is just justice.
Right? This is a just war because a
Trojan stole
Helen
and therefore the Greeks must
avenge the honor of Menelaus.
Okay? Second is family.
>> [snorts]
>> Helen should be with her children. Helen
should be with her family in Sparta. We
have to return her to Sparta.
How would I feel if Penelope was stolen
from me? I would everyone to go fight
with me to get her back as well, right?
About family.
Okay? Now, the third reason
is legacy.
Yes, he will not see
uh his son Telemachus for 20 years.
Therefore, he has to build him a legacy
that will carry him for the rest of his
life. If he is in Troy and he wins this
great war, he becomes this great hero,
then Telemachus himself will be famous
as the son of of Odysseus.
People respect Telemachus. He wants to
build a legacy for his son. He wants to
tell his son, "This is This is how you
should live your life. You should live a
life of honor, of justice, of truth."
Okay? So, these are the three reasons
why he goes to
um Troy.
And we have to remember that this is all
to justify his conflict, okay? There's a
conflict, there's a rupture in his soul,
and he he needs to mend it by explaining
why he's doing what he's doing.
Okay? Because again, he's abandoning his
family for 20 years.
Okay. [snorts]
So,
um
what's going to happen is this. This is
This is the worldview that Odysseus has
when he enters Troy.
The problem starts when they win the
war.
Okay? Because when they win the war,
then Odysseus is forced to see that all
of these three things
were wrong.
Okay?
He will discover that this war was not
about justice. It was just about revenge
and murder.
It isn't about family, it's about
destroying families. Because when you
win this war, you enslave the women and
kill the husbands.
Right? That's destroying families.
>> [snorts]
>> And it's not about legacy because
you've destroyed the Trojan civilization
for no particular reason. Because Helen
Helen doesn't even want to go back to
your Sparta.
Okay? And this causes cognitive
dissonance.
And this is what causes his PTSD.
Okay? Or trauma. And so for So the
Odyssey is his journey to repair his
soul so they can go home.
Okay? Does it Does it make sense, guys?
That's what the Odyssey is about. Okay.
So what we're going to do now is we are
going to
um
read certain sections. Okay? So this is
from the Iliad, actually. Okay? This is
from the Iliad.
And
And so remember in book one of the
Iliad, Achilles and Agamemnon have this
nasty fight where Achilles is like,
"Screw you. You're a dog. I'm not going
to fight for you ever again."
Agamemnon's like, "Screw you. I don't
need you." Okay? But in book two,
Agamemnon recognizes that, "Oh, this is
actually a problem because Achilles is
the greatest warrior that we have. And
if Achilles
doesn't want to fight, then that's bad
for morale."
Okay? We might actually even lose this
war. So Agamemnon, being stupid, he has
this stupid idea. And this stupid idea
is this: How can I rally my soldiers?
How can I galvanize them into action now
that Achilles has abandoned battlefield?
I know what I'll do.
I'll tell them they can go home. Ha!
Reverse psychology, guys, right? Reverse
psychology. Because when I say, "You
guys can go home,"
every Greek WILL BE LIKE, "NO! WE CAME
all the way to Troy to win glory for
you, Agamemnon.
We're going to fight to the death to
ensure that you get your glory,
AGAMEMNON. WE DON'T WANT TO GO HOME.
DON'T MAKE US GO HOME. WE WANT TO
FIGHT." OKAY? SO THAT'S THE PLAN.
And of course, it backfires.
And when people hear, "Oh, we go home,"
they all run away. And Agamemnon's like
He now is cognitive dissonance. He's
like
What? Uh what? He doesn't understand
what's going on, okay? And at this point
in the story, the war should be over
because all the Greeks just got went
home.
And again, what happens is
Odysseus will come and save everyone
because he will recognize that
Agamemnon's just being stupid and he
will force all the Greeks to
uh return back to their posts, okay? All
right. So, I Can Can you read, please?
Testing his men.
Testing his men, but he only made the
spirit race inside their chests. All the
rank and file who never heard his plan.
And the whole assembly surged like big
like big waves at sea, the Achaean sea
when east and south winds drive it on,
blasting down in force from the clouds
of father Zeus, or when the west wind
shakes the deep standing grain with her
with hurricane gusts that flatten down
the stalks.
So, the mass assembly of troops was was
shaken now.
They cried in alarm and charged towards
the ships, and the dust went whirling up
from under rushing feet as the men
jostled back and forth, shouting orders.
Grab all the ships. Drag them down to
the bright sea. Clean out the launching
channels.
Shrill shouts hitting the heavens,
fighters racing for home, knocking the
blocks out underneath the holes. Okay.
So, this just shows you how stupid
Agamemnon is because Agamemnon thinks
that his soldiers soldiers want to fight
this war. But all the soldiers are
homesick. They're sick of this stupid
war. They They don't even know why why
they're in this war, okay? So, the
moment that Agamemnon says, "You guys
You guys can go home." They're all like,
"We're We're going to get home as soon
as possible." Okay? They miss their
wives. They miss their children.
All right? So,
after they did and Hera are up up in the
sky, okay? Mount Olympus. And they They
They watch us and like, "Oh my god.
Agamemnon's going to lose us this war.
What a And Hera says to Athena,
oh sorry sorry sorry, it's not actually
Hera and Aphrodite, it's Hera and Athena
because they're the ones who lost the
contest to Aphrodite, okay? But Hera
says to Athena, YOU GET DOWN THERE, MAN,
and you stop this, okay? So Athena
rushes down and he talks to Odysseus,
okay?
All right, can you read?
And now they might have won their
journey home, the men of Argos fighting
the will of fate. Yes, if Hera had not
alerted Athena.
Inconceivable, child of Zeus whose
battle shield is thunder, tireless one,
Athena.
What, is this the way?
All the Argives flying home to their
fatherland, sailing over the seas broad
back. Leaving Priam and all the men of
Troy a trophy to glory over. Helen of
Argos, Helen for whom so many Argives
lost their lives in Troy, far from
native land.
Go, range the ranks of Achaeans arms in
bronze.
With your winning words, hold back each
man you find. Don't let them haul their
rolling ships to sea.
Good.
Keep on reading.
The bright-eyed goddess Pallas lost no
time.
Down she flashed from the peaks of Mount
Olympus, quickly reached the ships and
found Odysseus first, a mastermind like
Zeus, still standing fast.
He had not laid a hand in his back
black-benched hole, such anguish racked
from his heart and fighting spirit.
Now close beside him the bright-eyed
goddess stood and urged him on.
Royal son of
Laertes. Laertes, Odysseus, great
tactician.
What, is this the way?
>> Okay, so um so everyone's going to go
home and you would think that Odysseus
would be the first person to get on a
ship to go back to see his son and his
wife, okay? But he's he's
um standing there. He's kind of
confused.
All right? So, he's like, "This doesn't
make any sense to me. Why would
Agamemnon do this?" But at the same
time, he sort of shows you that he
actually doesn't really want to go home.
Right? Because if he really wanted to go
home, he'd be home by now. Turn on
going.
All you Argives flying home to your
fatherland, tumbling into your war-swept
ships, leaving Priam and old men of Troy
a trophy to glory over.
Helen of Argos. Helen of Argos, Helen
for whom so many Argives lost their
lives in Troy, far from native land.
No, don't give up now. Range the aching
ranks with your winning words, hold back
each man you find. Don't let them haul
their rolling ships to sea.
He knew the goddess's voice. He [snorts]
went on the run, flinging off his cape
as Eurybates picked it up. The herald of
of Ithaca always at his side.
Coming face to face with Atreides
Agamemnon, he relieved him of his
father's royal scepter. Its power can
never die, and grasping it tightly, off
he strode to the ships of Argives armed
in bronze. Okay. So, he's not going to
single-handedly save the Greeks from
losing this war, okay? So, um
Athena, right? Athena is always part of
Odysseus. It's part of his soul, right?
The intuition. And his intuition tells
him
something is something wrong here. I
need to stop this, okay?
Also, [snorts] what Look at Agamemnon.
Agamemnon is frozen. He He is so
distraught.
He's shut down, okay? His brain has
stopped working. It's frozen because
this is not supposed to happen, right?
When he says that you guys can go home,
he wanted everyone to say, "No, we're
going to stay and fight for you,
Agamemnon." All right? So, it's
cognitive cognitive dissonance.
It's so much cognitive dissonance that
when
um Odysseus takes the royal scepter,
everyone doesn't even notice. The royal
scepter is part of his soul, right? It's
his legacy. It's what gives him
authority. He's the king of kings. And
Odysseus just takes takes the crown from
him and says like, "No, I'm the king for
now to save this war."
Okay? And it just shows you how
committed Odysseus is to winning this
war. He really believes that this war is
about justice,
about family, about building a legacy
for his son. So, he refuses to lose this
war.
All right?
Keep on going?
I I thought I
>> Oh, sorry. Sorry. Uh yeah.
All right.
All right. So,
um
But, that's the Iliad, okay? And again,
what will happen is that Odysseus will
win this war and he'll win eternal glory
for himself with the stratagem of the
Trojan horse. All right?
Now, [snorts] we go
to the Odyssey. And in the Odyssey,
we don't actually meet Odysseus for many
many books, okay? It's only towards the
middle that we meet Odysseus. In the
first few books, it's it's a story of
Telemachus and his journey to find his
father, okay?
And when we meet Odysseus, he's a very
different person
from
when from the Iliad. Remember in the
Iliad, he is trying to win this war.
He's very energetic. He's galvanized.
He's very heroic.
Okay, but when we see him in the
Odyssey, he's a changed person. In fact,
he's a broken person. So, what's
happening is that um
Odysseus Odysseus and his crew try to go
home and get lost at sea. They have many
adventures. They get shipwrecked on an
island.
Um and he's and he becomes the sex toy,
okay, literally a sex toy of a goddess
named Calypso. All right? So, basically
he's getting whipped every day uh at
night
and then
uh he goes to the beach and he cries.
Okay? So,
uh
And so so so he's he he he's he's a
prisoner of Calypso for many years, and
the gods, Zeus, Athena, they get
together and and and say, "You know
what? We can't have this happen anymore,
okay? Uh this is needs to go home." So,
they send Hermes to tell Calypso, "You
have to send Odysseus home. The gods
will it." And Calypso says, "Sure, why
not?" Okay? So, can you read?
With that, the powerful giant killer
sped away.
>> it's Hermes, okay? So, Hermes has told
Calypso, "You have to let this guy go."
The queenly nymph sought out the great
Odysseus. The commands of Zeus still
rang in her ears, and found him there on
the headland, sitting still, weeping,
his eyes never dry, his sweet life
flowing away with the tears he wept for
his foiled journey home, since the nymph
no longer pleased. So, he's sitting,
he's still,
he's weeping, his eyes never dry,
and all he's thinking about is
the past, okay? This is clear signs of
depression.
PDST, okay?
Keep on going.
In the night, true, he'd sleep with her
in the in the arching cave. He had no
choice, unwilling lover alongside lover
all too willing. But all his days he sat
on rocks and beaches, wrenching his
heart with sobs and groans and anguish,
gazing out over the barren sea through
blinding tears.
>> Okay, so he's a broken man. As he's a
very different person from the Iliad,
okay? So, now the question then is, why?
What happened to him?
All right?
So, um Calypso says to Odysseus, "You
know what?
It's been great having a sex toy,
but the gods insist that you have to go
home. But you know what? You can all you
can choose to be my sex toy for all
eternity. I can make you immortal,
right? You can go home, but I can make
you immortal and you'll be my sex toy
for all eternity. Now, this is is like,
that's a really nice offer. I I really
want to do this, but I need to go to
home, okay? So, he leaves and he gets an
island.
And on this island, he's given a ship to
go home. Okay? But, before he goes home,
as the custom, they hold a banquet for
him.
Okay? And they really don't know who he
is. He
they don't really know he's Odysseus.
All right. So,
during the banquet,
um
what's the tradition is to have a bard
sing a great story. Okay? To sing a
story of great deeds. And of course, he
sings about the Trojan War, okay? So, so
can you read um
I I read. Yeah.
The strife between Odysseus and
Achilles, Peleus' son.
>> Okay. So, so the bard is singing about
the Trojan War, okay? Mhm.
How once at the gods' flowing feast, the
captains clash in the savage war of
words, while Agamemnon, lord of armies,
rejoiced at heart that Achaeus' bravest
men were battling so.
For this was the victory sign that
Apollo prophecies at shrine in Pytho
when Agamemnon strode across the rocky
threshold, asking the oracle for advice.
The start of the tidal waves of ruin
tumbling down on Troy's and Achaeus'
forces both at once, thanks to the will
of Zeus, who rules the world.
That was the song the famous harper
sang, but but Odysseus, clutching his
flaring sea-blue cape in both powerful
hands, drew it over his head and buried
his handsome face, ashamed his host
might see him shedding tears.
Whenever the rapt bard would pause in
the song, he'd lift the cape from his
head, wipe off his tears, and hoisting
his double-handed cup, poured out to the
gods.
But as But soon as the bard would start
again, impelled to sing by Phemius'
words, who reveled in the tale, again
Odysseus hid his hid his face and wept.
>> Okay, so this is great banquet. And uh
the bard sing about the Trojan War. And
at this point you think that Odysseus
would like, "Hey, that's me, man." He'd
be very proud. But instead he cries and
he cries, okay? This again is trauma.
Where
the memories are storing pain in him. So
clearly something happened
during the Trojan War that made him want
to forget about it. That made him resent
himself. Okay? That caused his soul to
be ruptured.
All right? All right. So
um
Keep on going?
Odysseus, master of many exploits,
praised the singer.
I respect you, Demodocus, more than any
man alive. Surely the Muse has taught
you, Zeus' daughter, or god Apollo
himself, how true to life, all too true,
you sing the Achaeans' fate, all they
did and suffered, all they soldiered
through, as if you were the as if you
were there yourself or heard from one
who was.
But come now, shift your ground. Sing of
the wooden horse Epeius built with
Athena's help, the cunning trap that
good Odysseus that good Odysseus brought
one day to the heights of Troy, filled
with fighting men who laid the city
waste. Sing that for me, true to life as
it deserves, and I will tell the world
at once how freely the Muse gave you the
gods' own gift of song.
>> Okay.
So he's feeling all this pain
because of memories of the Trojan War.
But he recognizes that if he's willing
to go home, because remember he's on his
journey home, he needs to confront his
pain. He needs to admit his pain.
Okay? So now he's going to ask the bard
to sing the memory that he's most trying
to repress. He's trying to He He wants
to now focus on the Trojan War and
really come to terms with his own
trauma. Okay?
All right. So this So So let's let Let's
see what happens.
Sorry.
Stirred now by the muse, the bard
launched out in the fine blaze of song,
starting at just the point where the
main Achaean force, setting their camps
a fire, had boarded the oar-swept ships
and sailed for home.
But famed Odysseus's men already
crouched in hiding in the heart of
Troy's assembly, darkened that horse the
Trojans dragged themselves to the city
heights.
Now it stood there, looming,
and round its bulk the Trojans sat
debating, clashing days on [music] end.
Three plans split ranks, either to hack
open the hollow vault with ruthless
bronze, or haul it up to the highest
ridge and pitch it down the cliffs, or
let it stand, a glorious offering made
to pacify the gods.
And that That final plan was bound to
win the day.
For Troy was fated to perish once the
city lodged inside her walls the
monstrous wooden horse, where the prime
of Argive power lay in wait with death
and slaughter bearing down on Troy.
Okay.
All right. And he's saying how Troops of
Achaeans
Achaeans broke from cover, streaming out
of the horse's hollow flanks to plunder
Troy.
He's saying how left and right they
ravaged the steep city,
saying how Odysseus marched right up to
Deiphobus's house, like the god of war
on attack with thy hard Menelaus. But
Deiphobus is a name for Priam, okay?
They They They want to go kill the king.
You know what I'm saying?
There, he's saying, Odysseus fought the
grimmest fight he had ever braved, but
he won through at last, thanks to
Athena's superhuman power.
That was the song the famous harper
sang. The great Odysseus melted into
tears running down from his eyes to wet
his cheeks.
As a woman weeps, her arms flung round
her darling husband, a man who fell in
battle fighting for town and townsmen
trying to beat the day of doom from home
and children.
Seeing the man go down, dying, gasping
for for breath, she clings for dear
life, screams and shrills. But the
victors just behind her digging spear
butts into her back and shoulders drag
her off in bondage, yoked to hard labor,
pain, and the most heartbreaking torment
waste her cheeks.
So, from Odysseus's eyes ran tears of
heartbreak. Okay, so now we know what
happened, okay?
All right, so what happened was this.
For 10 years, Odysseus and the Greeks
were trying to defeat the Trojans, and
they could not do it because the Trojans
were behind a walled city. So, Odysseus
prayed and prayed to Athena for
inspiration, and then one day, he had
it, the Trojan horse, okay? So, he
sneaks in So, he gets in into the
underbelly of the Trojan horse along
with other soldiers,
and then they get into the city, and
like, you know, they're really scared,
they're really excited.
Then they're able at night to
uh leave the Trojan horse and then open
the gates of Troy, and the Greeks stream
in, and they start to conquer the city.
And then Odysseus, you know, he is
killing, okay? Because it's war, and
he's full of adrenaline.
But then something catches his eye.
All right? He strikes down a soldier,
and then the a woman comes crying.
And
she's
traumatized at the sight of the death of
her husband.
And he's And Odysseus is traumatized by
this woman being traumatized. Because he
came to Troy
to save
the woman, right?
He sees Penelope in this woman. He says,
"I came all this way to make sure that
Helen could be safe with her husband."
And now he just recognized that I just
killed someone's husband.
But only that,
but
the Greeks come and they take her off to
be enslaved.
So, he
by winning this war has to has destroyed
every single family in Troy.
He's caused the suffering of thousands
and thousands of
women and children.
And that is what he sees for the first
time, okay? For the longest time he
believed that he was here to fight for
justice, to save families, to leave a
legacy for his son Telemachus. And now
he recognizes, "No.
This is not a just war.
I'm destroying
a civilization. This is not a war about
family. This is This is a war about
destroying families. And what am I What
legacy am I leaving my son?
How will my son feel if he knows how I
destroyed families like ours?
And this causes trauma in him. It splits
his soul.
And it drives him crazy, basically. And
that's the conflict, the central
conflict in the Odyssey.
Having
done so much evil, how can you go home?
How can you repair yourself?
How can you mend your soul and repair
your worldview so that you can live for
your family?
Okay?